salut bienvenue dans ce hre une histoire
un petit peu à la Bellem on va parler
d'une escroquerie de la fin du 19e
siècle qui avait défrayé la chronique en
France on va parler d'un faux procès de
17 ans du château de la Star academmie
de centaines de millions de francs et de
Thérèse imaginez Thérèse dorignac une
jeune femme qui est issue d'une famille
dont le père est lui-même un petit
escroc rien que le dorignac est faux
puisque la particule des apostrophe
c'est son père qui l'a inventé ils
habitent dans une ferme qui s'appelle la
ferme aux illers mais que le père fait
appeler le château des illers son métier
est pas très clair il est matrimonial il
est vignoble amateur il est aussi
guérisseur il est un petit peu tout ce
qui lui permet de ramener de l'argent
facilement à la maison mais
régulièrement pour le père de Thérèse
les affaires sont pas très bonnes alors
il a une astuce une escroquerie qu'on
appelle la mal espagnole ça consiste à
faire croire qu'on est détendeur d'un
énorme héritage mais à cause d'une
difficulté juridique on n'a pas accès à
cet héritage et évidemment le juridique
ça coûte cher à financer donc on trouve
des personnes pour faire le financement
et nous aider à débloquer la situation
juridique évidemment on s'entend sur sur
un accord on fera moî moite de ce
fabuleux héritage qui n'existe pas
thérèe a deux frères et une sœur avec
qui elle s'entend très bien d'ailleurs
toute la famille s'entend très bien ils
sont très heureux c'est une famille très
soudée et ça va être utile pour la suite
baigné dans l'art de l'escroquerie
thérèe enfant va commencer elle aussi
faire ses petites combines et une fois
jeune fille quand elle sortait avec sa
sœur pour aller voir des garçons par
exemple elle mettait tous les bijoux
qu'elles avaient pour faire croire
qu'elles étaient très riches l'une comme
l'autre car elles avaient un but
réaliser un beau mariage avec quelqu'un
de richissime au-delà du richissime
d'ailleurs Thérèse voulait rentrer dans
la haute société à l'âge de 20 ans thérè
rencontre Frédéric Ambert c'est le fils
de Gustave Ambert c'est pas n'importe
qui il est procureur général à la Cour
des comptes et il est professeur de
droit à la faculté de Toulouse Gustave a
rencontré le père de thérè parce qu'il
lui avait vendu du vin ils se sont bien
entendus et c'est comme ça que thérè va
rencontrer Frédéric et en tombe
amoureuse sincèrement amoureuse frédéric
est en train de terminer ses études de
droit quant à Thérèse elle ne rentre pas
dans les critères de beauté qu'apprécie
Frédéric mais elle a quelque chose pour
elle elle a son intelligence et ses
talents de persuasion alors petit à
petit la relation va se créer et
Frédéric va terminer par tomber lui
aussi amoureux de Thérèse mais c'est pas
du goût de Gustave qui va s'opposer à un
mariage pourquoi à cause d'une
différence de niveau de vie des deux
familles il il supporte pas que son fils
se marie avec quelqu'un qui n'a pas de
finances en fait derrière elle et qui
pourrait en plus potentiellement
profiter de lui donc il va s'y opposer
fermement et c'est là que Thérèse va
mettre en place sa première grande
escroquerie et ne croyez pas que c'est
le sujet de la vidéo parce que ça c'est
que le début elle va suivre les traces
de son père et reprendre le coup de la
malle espagnole elle va dire qu'elle est
l'unique héritière d'une très riche
cousine qui possède le château de de
Mercotte qui possède énormément de biens
et qui lui a tout légué et ça fonctionne
Gustave va tomber dans le panneau il va
donner sa bénédiction pour le mariage il
faut dire que Théresa a un très bon jeu
de comédienne elle sait se montrer
timide elle sait se montrer
impressionnée elle a un léger zeotement
qui est relativement mignon et qui
inspire la confiance spontanément à ce
moment de l'histoire je vous le partage
je suppose que Frédéric était au courant
il y a rien pour étayer ça il y a rien
pour le prouver mais quand vous allez
voir son rôle dans les prochaines
histoires ça me paraît assez un
vraisemblable qu'il n'était pas au
courant dès cette première escocré quant
à thérè elle poursuit ses combines elle
va par exemple se faire coiffer
gratuitement par un grand coiffeur qui
coûte 8000 francs c'est une fortune à
l'époque elle va pas le payer de toute
manière elle lui dit qu'elle va le payer
plus tard et elle arrive à faire mieux
que ça elle arrive à lui faire payer les
fleurs la location de voiture et cetera
lui avancer l'argent toujours sur des
prétexte fallacieux de son héritage
héritage qui n'arrivera jamais hein
qu'on soit bien d'accord avec ça alors à
un moment donné elle a dû l'assumer et
donc elle a prétexté que le notaire qui
s'était occupé de ça avait confondu son
acte de naissance avec l'acte de
naissance de sa jeune sœur qui était
décédée en basage sœur qui n'a jamais
existé sur notre sœur elle vit elle va
très bien thérè et Frédéric deviennent
très complices très complices aussi des
escroqueries des combines des arnaque le
rôle de thérè c'est de mentir et de
savoir jouer la comédie le rôle de
Frédéric c'est de connaître le droit ils
peuvent donc monter des choses
extrêmement crédibles puisque Frédéric
sait quel pion il faut avancer jusqu'au
jour où ils vont avoir l'opportunité de
faire la plus grande escroquerie de la
fin du 19e siècle Gustave Humbert le
père de Frédéric vient d'être nommé
ministre de la justice c'est pas rien
surtout à cette époque ça a des éclats
incroyables dans les petits milieux et
thérè et Frédéric compent bien profiter
de cette notoriété qui les éclabousse la
base est très simple thérèe veut refaire
le coup de la malle espagnole mais c'est
plus une malle c'est une valise c'est un
compartiment entier de valise il faut se
rendre compte quand même que la mal
espagnole c'est l'une des escroqueries
les plus délicates parce qu'on va devoir
se confronter à des notaires à des
banquiers à des avocats des personnes
qui sont tout sauf naïves et qui vont
être très réticentes à avancer l'argent
d'un héritage ces personneslà vont
vérifier la réalité de l'héritage la
validité de la succession et cetera mais
Thérèse a une idée de génie pour
pasalier à tout ça pour éviter qu'on
vérifie la viabilité de cet héritage qui
de toute manière n'existe pas elle va
monter une fausse bataille juridique
entre elle et un qu adverse qui se Batt
pour le même héritage qui va rendre tout
de suite sa légitimité vraie puisqu'elle
est dans une bataille juridique du coup
il n'y a pas à vérifier si l' rérétage
est vrai ou pas puisque de toute manière
il y a déjà une bataille juridique pour
l'obtenir c'est bien qu'il existe et
c'est l'histoire qui vont raconter à
leurs amis à leur famille aux
professionnels aux journaux également et
là on va se délecter des rebondissements
qui vont expliquer tout le stratagème
THz créé le personnage fictif de Henry
Robert Crawford un richissime américain
ami de la famille d'orignnac plus
spécialement ami de la mère de Thérèse
avec qui il aurait eu Thérèse en enfant
illégitime le 6 septembre 1877 il aurait
fait un testament dans lequel il lègue
l'intégralité de ses biens et de ses
liquidités à sa fille légitime Thérèse
dorignac ça représente quand même plus
de 100 millions de francs fin du 19e
c'est énorme quand Thérèse révèle
publiquement qu'elle va obtenir cet
héritage là et toute son histoire tous
les usuriers les banquiers les notaires
se précipitent à elle en plus qui est la
belle fille quand même du ministre de la
Justice pour lui prêter de l'argent en
attendant qu'elle touche son héritage et
puis chacun joue sa partie c'estàd qu'il
veulent bien lui prêter de l'argent mais
avec de très très gros intérêts donc il
vont être gagnant aussi le temps qu'elle
touche le pactol pour thérèe et Frédéric
cette direction avenue de la Grande
Armée ils prennent un somptueux
appartement et là ils commencent à vivre
la belle vie mais retournement de
situation au moment d'empocher
l'héritage thérè révèle qu'il a un
problème un contre-temps un autre
testament existe cet autre testament dit
léguer l'intégralité de la fortune à la
sœur de Thérèse Marie dorignac et à ses
deux neveux Henry et Robert Crawford
dans la loi française il est dit que le
dernier testament est gageur donc le
plus récent dans la rédaction l'emporte
sur tous les testaments précédents sauf
que le deuxième testament a été écrit le
même jour selon Thérèse et les deux
neveux Crawford était quelqu'un de
fantasque c'est tout à fait possible qu'
l' effectivement pu écrire les deux t
amment le même jour donc bon pas de bol
on peut pas récupérer l'héritage alors
qu'est-ce qui se passe déjà il faut
jouer la partie adverse qui va incarner
Henry et Robert crofford et bien c'est
pas compliqué c'est Romain et Émile
dorignac les frères de Thérèse qui vont
se faire passer pour des richissimes
américains c'est d'autant plus simple
que les échange entre la famille cwford
et la famille dorignac se passe
principalement par courrier puisque la
famille cwford habite aux États-Unis
tous les courriers sont écrits par
Thérèse les courriers des deux parties
de toute manière cell qui mène la danse
et les Crawford les faux Crawford vont
aller jusqu'à prendre un avocat à Paris
pour défendre leur intérêt et récupérer
leur héritage l'avocat que les Crawford
vont engager à Paris n'est pas au
courant que c'est une supercherie donc
lui il va défendre sincèrement l'intérêt
de ses clients et c'est là que ça
devient intéressant parce que ça
crédibilise tout on a plus des personnes
en train de mentir publiquement on a des
personnes comme l'avocat descrawford qui
dit la vérité quand il parle de cette
histoire il ne sait pas que tout cela
est faux tout cela est fait bien sûr
dans le but de gagner du temps et de
continuer d'embaucher l'argent des
banquiers des usuriers des notaires
rapidement on tombe dans un véritable
table flou juridique il y a aucune issue
possible mais heureusement thérèe
dorignac et les neveux Crawford trouvent
un terrain d'entente c'est ok pour que
thérè touche l'intégralité de l'héritage
à la condition qu'elle verse 6 millions
de francs aux deux neveux Crawford donc
ça va c'est bon un accord va être signé
tout va bien ça redonne de l'espoir aux
usuriers qui ont prêtit de l'argent qui
se disent ok on va récupérer quand même
ce qu'on a prêté alors c'est long bien
sûr c'est très très long pour toucher un
héritage de cette somme surtout entre
deux pays qui sont sépar par
l'Atlantique mais tout le monde est sûr
et certain d'une chose c'est que Thérèse
dorignac et est à la tête d'une immense
fortune en plus c'est elle qui possède
le coffre dans le coffre il y aurait 100
millions de francs sous forme de titre
d'action de choses comme ça qui
suffirait de revendre ce donc plus
qu'une question de semaine avant que
tout le monde en profite le temps passe
thérè est de plus en plus riche elle
continue à mener la grande vie avec
Frédéric dans leur bel appartement
l'avenue de la Grande Armée le leur amis
ce sont des notaires c'est c'est la
bourgeoisie c'est le système politique
c'est des avocats c'est des médecins
thérè est tout à fait à la place de la
haute société dont elle avait toujours
rêvé et avec les moyens de vivre cette
vielà il est temps de finaliser
seulement coup de théâtre au moment où
Thérèse veut faire valoir ses droits les
neveux refuse de signer l'accord comme
par hasard ils vont se défendre ils
prétendent qu'ils avaient accepté à la
base cet accord parce que la sœur de
thérèe Marie dorignac avait accepté
d'épouser l'un des deux neveux donc avec
ce mariage tout l'héritage serit dans la
même famille donc c'était ok pour
seulement marie vient de refuser juste
là de d'épouser l'un des deux neveux
Crawford donc il refuse de signer
d'accord c'est caduc alors ils sont très
fermes ils l'annoncent publiquement ils
veulent récupérer leur héritage et là va
commencer une bataille juridique qui va
durer 17 ans c'est énorme 17 ans de
bataille juridique publique avec des
personnes qui n'existe pas pour un
héritage qui n'existe pas durant 17 ans
thérè va mettre en scène des obstacles
qui l'empêche de toucher l'héritage elle
va être aidée par Frédéric son mari qui
qui est très très bon en droit et
surtout qui est très très bon en
procédure pour toujours trouver des
moyens de repousser le verdict du
jugement et pour parfaire un petit peu
l'histoire parce que 17 ans quand même
faut tenir les gens en Alline et faut
tenir la crédibilité les neveux Crawford
de temps en temps se montrent
publiquement lorsqu'ils viennent en
France je vous rappelle que ce sont
simplement les frères de thérèsee dorgac
donc ils viennent ils donnent des des
conférences pour la presse ils
rencontrent des gens il rencontent leur
avocat donc il y a aucune raison de se
dire que c'est une arnaque ça donne au
contraire une bonne histoire qui est
bien suivie en France ça va faire couler
beaucoup d'encre tous les journaux en
parlent et relatent ça un petit peu
comme un feuilleton parce que c'est plus
qu'une bataille entre avocats ça va
aller jusqu'à la Cour de cassation quand
même un procès avec des gens qui
n'existent pas pour un héritage qui
n'existe pas alors que fait thérè
pendant ce temps-là ben m la belle vie
avec Frédéric tout se passe très bien
pour eux ils vont même en 1882 acheter
un château près de Melin le château des
vives eau ça se trouve à Damarie lélis
pour la petite anecdote c'est le château
dans lequel a été tourné les épisodes de
la star academmie vous dez bien qu'il y
a quand même des personnes qui de temps
en temps s'inquiètent un petit peu et
trouve ça un poil Longué par exemple un
banquier qui avait prêté énormément
d'argent à thérè et Frédéric qui
commence à douter de la véracité de tout
ça alors thérè l'invite au château des
vibzo parce que justement Crawford doit
venir passer quelques jours pour
discuter l'héritage et trouver une issue
favorable lui dit mais ça tombe bien
venez le weekend prochain au château des
pivzo parce que euh Robert Crawford doit
venir donc vous allez le rencontrer en
chernous et vous allez voir qu'il existe
qu'il y a pas de problème le banquier
accepte il arrive là-bas pour le weekend
manque de bol un télégramme de Robert
Crawford arrive en tout cas soit-disant
c'est ce que lui raconte thérè en disant
que Robert a eu un empêchement et
malheureusement ne peut pas venir le
banquier ne croit pas du tout cette
version des faits et là il se dit ok
c'est sûr je me suis fait avoir sur
toute la ligne de toute manière il faut
bien qu'il aille dormir là parce que le
château est un petit peu long il rent
entrera le lendemain donc il va dans sa
chambre pour y passer la nuit il fait un
petit peu les SAS et et la poubelle de
la Chambre a oublié d'être vidée par les
domestiques du château et du coup il
regarde un petit peu et il y trouve une
lettre et la lettre c'est le télégramme
de Robert Crawford qui qui a été reçu lu
et jeté ici et et oublié d'être nettoyé
et à partir de ce moment-là il recroit
pleinement à toute l'histoire alors
qu'évidemment Ctait re qui a fait ce
faux télégramme qui l'a siamment mis
dans la poubelle de la ch du banquier
comme si le domestique avait oublié de
la vider elle était très maline en 1886
des années après le début de cette
querelle juridique le tribunal affirme
que la seule détentrice légitime de
l'héritage est thérèe elle va enfin
pouvoir prendre possession de ces 100
millions de francs qui n'existent pas à
l'issue d'un procès pour un héritage qui
n'existe pas avec une partie adverse qui
n'existe pas belle justice alors une
procédure en amenant une autre ça va
prendre des années avant que thérèe
puisse prendre possession de l'héritage
jusqu'au jour où le journal Le Matin qui
est le journal le plus lu à l'époque va
publier un article qui va faire
sensation où il affirme que les Humber
donc thérèe et Frédéric sont des escrocs
ils étaillent un petit peu leur propos
ça va faire ouvrir une enquête l'enquête
va être menée et on va découvrir que
l'adresse l'adresse des Crawford à
laquelle arrivent tous les courriers est
un squir aux États-Unis qui a pas de
maison là-bas le 2 mai 1902 le tribunal
de Paris ordonne l'ouverture du coffre
de Thérèse KOF qui est censé contenir
tous les documents sur lesquels il
s'appuie depuis le départ les titres les
actions toute la richesse la police
arrive au domicile le domicile est vide
il n'y reste plus rien à part le coffre
vide lui
aussi Frédéric et thérè vont être
retrouvés ils vont être retrouvés en
Espagne et jugés lors d'un procès du 8
août 1903 à la cour d'assise en étant
défendu par un avocat un ténor du
barreau par n'importe lequel c'est
l'avocat de l'affaire de rfus et les
jurés vont se montrer bienveillants et
l'opinion aussi ils vont on pas écopé
d'une très lourde peine 5 ans de prison
pour Thérèse et Frédéric et 4 ans et 3
ans pour les deux frères de Thérèse
alors est-ce que les jurés sont
impressionné par le génie de Thérèse
sûrement le cas il est fort probable
aussi que ils ont certainement
représenté pour le commun des mortel
tout nous faisons partie des personnes
qui ont su se jouer du haut système des
hautes fonctions de la politique de la
haute bourgeoisie et qu'ils ont été non
pas vu comme des Robins des bois parce
qu'il gardaient l'argent pour eux mais
en tout cas des personnes qui ont réussi
à à
ceux qui ont tout versus ceux qui n'ont
rien je pense que c'est ce qui peut
expliquer la légèreté de la peine fait
remarquable les plus belles histoires de
génie dans l'escroquerie que que je peux
connaître avec des personnes qui ne se
sont pas toujours faites attraper
d'ailleurs sont orchestré par des femmes
qui ont une intelligence hors paèire et
qui ont l'habitude de vrer dans l'ombre
ou de paraître un petit peu timide en
tout cas c'est en partant d'une
escroquerie similaire d'une voleuse de
diamants qui n'a jamais été arrêtée que
j'ai créé un jeu de société qui
s'appelle arnaque bluff et diamant c'est
un jeu qui se joue de deux à quatre
joueurs qui est basé sur une histoire
vraie ça mélange le bluff la course à
l'obtention de certaines cartes parce
que vous incarnez une équipe en fait de
d'escrot qui veulent reproduire
justement l'escroerie de cette jeune
femme qui est bien expliqué dedans et en
même temps ça se tire un petit peu la
Bour ça essaye de faire tomber l'autre
de fuir la police bref vous avez un lien
dans la description j'ai fait une vidéo
pour présenter la sortie du jeu sur ma
chaîne c'est quand qu'on joue si vous
voulez regarder ça ça me fera très
plaisir j'en suis bien fier et surtout à
très bientôt
Ciao